hallo ihr lieben falls es bei euch auch
mal was ganz besonderes sein soll zum
frühstück dann kann ich euch dieses plan
brot mit käse und bei wärmstens
empfehlen
das fladenbrot was wir benutzen muss gar
nicht mal so frisch sein es kann also
auch durchaus einen sein was schon ein
paar tage länger bei euch ne küche steht
wir benötigen außerdem ein paar
geschnittene tomaten 1 1 etwas salz
geschmolzene butter und käse und hier
nehme ich am allerliebsten café keese
nun wird das fladenbrot vorbereitet und
dafür wird in der mitte ein kleiner
kreis ausgeschnitten last aber unbedingt
noch einen dicken rand denn da kommt
gleich noch käse hinein und ausschnitt
unglaublich lecker bei diesem schritt
ist zu beachten dass sie nicht zu viel
fladenbrot herausnimmt damit kein loch
entsteht
damit die ränder des fladenbrot nach dem
backen nicht steinhart werden müssen wir
auf jeden fall hier auch nochmal den
teig entfernen und dann geht es weiter
mit unserem käse und den reibe ich hier
schön sein
jetzt werden die ränder des fladenbrot
schön reichlich gefüllt mit dem käse und
anschließend auch ein wenig die
oberfläche
anschließend streichen wir etwas
flüssiger butter auf die oberfläche und
geben dann unseres jobs darauf
in die mitte gebe ich dann noch ein ei
und salze ist ein wenig
nun gebe ich noch die tomaten hinzu und
bei der erfüllung könnt ihr wirklich
total variabel sein also nimmt das was
ihr am liebsten mit oder was ihr euren
gästen am liebsten servieren möchte und
dann bestreitet sie nur noch die ränder
mit der butter und gibt das ganze in den
ofen
bei mir waren das jetzt circa 10 minuten
bei 180 grad ober und unterhitze und
nach dem backen bestreite ich die ränder
auch wieder mit etwas butter
das gibt nochmal glanz und geschmack und
dann ist das ganze auch schon fertig und
die könnte in aller ruhe ihr frühstück
genießen
anschließend habe ich das pendel noch
mit frischer petersilie aus garniert und
dann haben wir uns das alle schmecken
lassen
am leckersten schmeckt europa jetzt
natürlich noch warm oder noch besser
ganz frisch aus dem ofen denn dann könnt
ihr diesen schönen warmen käse genießen
das und euer job und falls euch das
video gefallen hat dann freue ich mich
sehr auf euer feedback wenn ihr es nach
macht und sagt bis zum nächsten mal auf
die disk icici ps falls ihr jetzt noch
zwei weitere frühstücks ideen sehen
wollt dann klickt hier links auf eines
der zwei videos und hier rechts auf den
button könnt ihr mich gerne abonnieren
damit ihr auch nichts mehr von mir
verpasst so jetzt aber schluss